hey let's talk about our favorite Bush
dwelling press secretary Sean Spicer -
absolutely
no one's surprise White House press
secretary Sean Spicer is on his way out
as White House press secretary this is
being framed as both a promotion for
Sean Spicer and a some kind of complex
strategic decision a realignment of
roles blah blah blah
this is Spicer being pushed out because
he's terrible at his job and the
background is that yesterday we learned
that the latest press briefing from the
White House Sean Spicer had already
kicked out cameras from some of these
press briefings yesterday he also didn't
allow audio recording of the press
briefing it's a press briefing used to
report about the White House's position
on things very important things the
quote Donald Trump what's the point if
nobody can record audio or video of it
so we knew early in the day yesterday
that something wasn't looking good and
now we have learned from White House
officials in a statement yesterday that
they have quote sought input from many
people as they look to expand the
communications operation as he did in
the beginning Sean Spicer is managing
both the communications and press office
he will continue to fill the role of
communications director that is a role
that has been empty since the end of May
after the person in that role Mike
dubbed ki rasoi
he will not be doing the press briefings
this is a firing in all but name
you don't move someone out of that role
it is an important position it is a very
visible position you don't move someone
out of that role if they are doing a
good job you find someone else to run
the communications department and the
technicality that they're using pat is
hey you know what communications
director is technically a higher
position than press secretary which is
true but you don't get rid of your
public spokesperson if they're doing a
good job I wonder why this is happening
now though because Sean Spicer has been
disgracing himself on national TV for a
long time and stay one and of course
Trump kept them around because the guy
gets good ratings but I think it really
comes down to death by a thousand cuts
it's not there's no coup de Gras moment
here there's no wind right
no possible wind because on day one
Spicer had to go out there and defend
the indefensible which was to argue that
indeed Donald Trump did have the record
inauguration crowd that he claimed to
have and what I what I'm wondering is
does the Trump administration think that
Spicer is the problem Spicer is a
symptom it's Donald Trump who made on
day one the assertion that he had record
inauguration turnout and who on day one
directed his press secretary to go out
and claim that he had a record
inauguration crowd Spicer was a symptom
of the problem it could have been
anybody going out there to make that
case and it would have been a disaster
but I think it's fair to say that Spicer
didn't help mitigate any of those
problems and I think maybe we should
come up with a montage of the top five
spiciest Sean Spicer moment we would
need to go more than five yeah I think
capped off by the inauguration crowd
sighs fiasco
yeah and Hitler's use of chemical
weapons those would definitely be
included there but I think we would
probably need it to be like the top 15
to even do justice to the last few
months Laura Ingraham right-wing radio
host reportedly being considered for the
position apparently Sarah Huckabee
Sanders the deputy press secretary not
being considered for the position which
is interesting because reportedly Donald
Trump has liked the job that she is done
when filling in for Sean Spicer so we
will see but yet another one bites the
dust lots of discussion about this on
our reddit discussion forum which you
can join at david pakman.com slash
reddit today's episode of the david
pakman show is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker
recently did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which ones you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription in
- I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like in
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very
very high even over $300 for
prescription glasses with Warby Parker
they started just 95 bucks mine cost
that including lenses and for every pair
sold they give a pair to someone in need
so to try the five pairs and support the
David Pakman show go to Warby Parker
trial comm /t DPS